hallo mein name ist flughafen lebens
zuschauer vor einigen tagen aber ich
bereits auf die witzigsten iphone elf
mails reagiert und das video bei euch
mega gut ankam habe ich mir gedacht da
gehe ich heute zum zweiten mal auf
einige der lustigsten iphone 11 min wir
sehen die miss rhein stürzen zeige ich
eben unter euch denn noch nicht
mitbekommen hat wie das iphone 5 aus und
erst mal ganz kurz wie es aussieht
und zwar so quasi wie ein 3 kopf
rasierer und es gibt nicht nur das
normale iphone elf sondern es gibt auch
noch eine pro version davon
wie heißt dein iphone 11 pro und von dem
jetzt auch noch eine größere version und
die heißt ein iphone 11 promax bei der
apple event vorstellung kam das ganze
dann in etwas so überhitzt sei von allen
promax sport und die erwartungen an das
neue iphone waren mal wieder riesig
allerdings war es die letzten jahre eher
so dass es viel mehr sachen entfernt hat
als dass ich sachen hinzugefügt haben
zum beispiel beim iphone 7 gab es keine
kopfhörer mehr dazu beim iphone hat
keinen home-button ein vom neuen wird
komplett raus gelassen von 10 hatte
keinen start und dass ein von 11 haben
sich dann sehr viele leute einfach so
versteckt ja das wird dann doch nicht so
sondern es wird halt so vorgestellt und
zwar kam eine weitere kamera dazu genaue
apple fans haben nun allerdings die
maske abgenommen gesehen dass es quasi
eigentlich nur ein iphone 10 darunter
ist aber wir haben ganz viele neue
kameras beim iphone 11
ja wie wird denn das sei von 12 aussehen
vielleicht so was ist wenn dann freut
das iphone 12 hat und dann sagt hey ich
war ein foto von dir schon mal die
kamera dann guckt man wahrscheinlich so
und ich habe da was ja nee also real
talk ich weiß nicht ob ich der einzige
bin der so denkt aber ich brauch an
meinem handy keine unfassbar kranke
kamera
ich mein ich finde mein iphone 10 jetzt
gerade kann schon alles was ich wir
haben 19 mir von dem iphone oder von
einem smartphone allgemein erwartet habe
allerdings wird es wahrscheinlich eh
irgendwann er so sein so dass handys
sich immer mehr zu einer kamera
entwickeln und ich mein wenn man jetzt
das iphone 11 sich kaufen von einer
person foto macht dann sieht man ja
schon aus holz schwarzenegger der einen
raketenwerfer in der hand hält ja das
habe ich euch aus dem letzten video von
den iphone elf teams gezeigt und da wird
jetzt tatsächlich auch eine hülle von
gemacht schwarzenegger da die stifter
geht werfer mit der kamera da halt ich
liebe die kreativität die einige leute
im internet haben und beispielsweise
wurde das einfach auch verglichen mit
dominosteinen dann unter anderem auch
mit einem herd auf dem man sicher kohle
erhitzt und nun ja hier wird einfach
eine packung tabletten da hingelegt und
das sieht genauso aus wie die kamera vom
iphone 11 ich weiß nicht wie oft ich in
diesem video schon wieder geklatscht
habe und ich weiß auch nicht ob ich
wirklich der einzige wenn er das design
des neuen iphones zu komplett
grottenschlecht findet vielleicht findet
ja auch einige unfassbar schön
allerdings sind für alle die es auch
nicht so schön finden habe ich auch noch
an ihm vorbereitet und zwar dieser
höhlen hersteller einfach mit seiner
iphone 11 hülle geworben mit dem satz
cover your disappointed also mit unseren
hüllen kannst du deine enttäuschung über
das iphone 11 design verstecken
aber das ist richtig geile werbung von
den höhen hersteller
apropos hüllen hättet ihr bock dass ich
mal wieder reinschauen
ob die mir ein paar höhen zu senden
wollen und neue von 11 dass ich das
einfach wieder durch die gegen schweizer
schreibt zwar gerne in die kommentare
ich hätte auf jeden fall bock drauf dann
würde ich meine freundin dabei räume
anschauen allerdings zurück zu den - und
zwar schaut man sich ja bevor man sich
so ein gerät wie das iphone 11 kauft
nicht nur die specs an die
beispielsweise kamera leistungen et
cetera sondern man schaut ja primär auch
auf den preis und das iphone 11 pro
kostet 1000 euro
es ist halt so teuer wie 12.000 kleine
waffel snacks und es ist beispielsweise
auch genauso teuer wie 83 mal der dritte
teil von shrek auf blu-ray gehe mit den
neuen preisen wurde dann auf der
apple-website auch eine neue
bezahlmethode hinzugefügt und zwar kann
man nun mit seiner lunge bezahlen
wer kommt auch so war allerdings haben
wir jetzt bereits über kamera gesprochen
wenn über das hässliche design
gesprochen wenn wir bei den preis
gesprochen allerdings noch gar nicht
über die akkuleistung und da hat apple
bei dem event gesagt all day battery
life also die batterie soll einen ganzen
tag lang halten auf der website stand
dann allerdings battery life bereits bei
use das heißt batterie hätten nicht
einen ganzen tag lang
das macht vorne und hinten keinen sinn
genau sie diese scheiße aussage bei der
wasserfestigkeit des iphones gibt es das
wort wasserfestigkeit überhaupt auf
jeden fall wurde auch gesagt hey unser
iphone ist wasserfest das ganze mit
schwimmen gehen bleiben aber nur bis
drei meter tiefe und dann höchstens vier
minuten oder so wenn du danach und das
noch am handymarkt und dreimal dürft ihr
raten dessen handy dabei auf ibiza
kaputtgegangen ist genau meinst aber
gerade hinsichtlich battery life also
akkuleistung und wasserfest dann wird
mich eure meinung in den kommentaren
interessieren ich weiß nicht ob es an
mir liegt oder ob man handy wirklich ein
hardware-fehler hat aber bei mir ist es
wirklich so dass mein handy aus einfach
ausgeht wenn es zehn prozent hat oder 5
prozent oder 3 und ich denke mir egal
wie wenig prozent das sind ich habe noch
prozent warum geht man denn die auster
verlässt man sich halt irgendwie drauf
und bezüglich wasser fest es ist halt
auch so wie bereits gerade gesagt ich
war damit auf ibiza ich bin in einem
normalen pool nicht irgendwie mehr
wasser keine ahnung was und das training
danach geladen und das ist einfach
kaputt gegangen es ist nicht irgendwie
ausgegangen oder sowas einfach kaputt
gegangen ich muss mein neues handy
kaufen er wird dann gesagt ihr müsst
jetzt möglich die rechtsordnung wird
also wie findet ihr das schreiben dass
man in die kommentare und falls die
tipps hat viel mit akku problem auch
genug mir die kommentare also man darf
sich wirklich nie so richtig auf die
getroffenen aussagen von
apple-mitarbeitern verlassen und genauso
ist es auch auf der website hier gewesen
mit denen farben bei dem rechten iphone
11 haben sie zum beispiel extra im
hintergrund gewählt so dass man oben
noch diesen diese kante sieht für die
base camp für die innen kamera und bei
den anderen modellen der links haben sie
extra in schwarzem hintergrund gewählt
und mit einer welle die auch oben links
dann so leicht abschneidet so dass man
denkt hey da ist gar nicht die kante
oben von der kamera
das sind dann wieder so die marketing
tricks und dass apple auch noch gesagt
hat bei den apple event ist dass das
iphone 11 das krasseste handy sei was
gegen hinfallen keine ahnung was für
crash alles mögliche geschützt sein
und dann hab ich mal ein bisschen
recherchiert und hat ein video gefunden
beide personen sein iphone elf hat
einfallen lassen
bis 8
ich glaube ist gar nichts mehr apples
erstes habe ich ein video vorbereitet
was jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein mist im
sinne von hey wir machen uns über apple
lustig und die kamera und das design und
den preis echt sondern es ist mehr eine
art frank und zwar schaut euch das video
einfach an jetzt eine frau die telefonie
mit dem neuen iphone 11 pro allerdings
seht ihr schon die person zum 3 nun habe
ich euch allerdings glaube ich auch
genug - und videos bilder et cetera
gezeigt zum neuen iphone elf
beziehungsweise zum neuen iphone 11 pro
allerdings an alle unter euch die das
event nicht gesehen haben hier nochmal
ein paar ausschnitte wie es komplett
unbearbeitet stattgefunden hat
danke
das samsung galaxy s tennis fans aber im
endeffekt ja genauso lief das ab das
event an dem ich das heute wieder ist
alex aber ende meine lieben freunde wenn
euch meine mittlerweile schon zweite
reaktion auf iphone elf teams gefallen
da würde ich mich wieder sehr toll aber
einen daumen hoch von euch unter dem
video freundschaft mit 50.000 licon das
ist ein mega krank das wird mir auf
jeden fall wieder zeigen
mich hat es gefallen und eventuell sogar
bock auf noch einen dritten teil von 11
- also das internet hat auf jeden fall
genug dafür an material zu bieten
schreibt mir das auf jeden fall gern
unten in die kommentare peter bock drauf
hätte und abonniert zudem gerne unter
dem video auch meinen kanal ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
ich sehe man dass jeder zweite der sich
meine videos anschaut gar nicht abonnent
ist und da frage ich mich einfach hey
warum
und wenn du schon abonnent ist würde ich
mich auch sehr freuen wenn du auf die
glocke klicken würdest denn dann
bekommst du es automatisch eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und vielleicht auch im
dritten teil von diesen elf teams mache
also da will ich mich auf jeden fall
sehr darüber freuen ich bin immer noch
ein bisschen erkältet von entschuldige
ich mich für meine stimme und gehe jetzt
wieder kotzen
[Musik]